[Applause]
yes season 2 is awesome it's always good
to be on you know we got a full order so
we're back 24 episodes excited it's like
we have this thing actually to call did
a good neighbor that we do on here
because I feel like people don't talk to
your neighbors honey born like do you
know your neighbors I know them you know
like you know an la neighbor hey the
people with the dogs I know them that's
a that's all you really know about your
neighbors oh they got the little dogs
this little that is true yeah if there's
not a crisis going on you never but yeah
like I have like I have one neighbor
he's got like this really big house that
you know so you just kind of go by every
time he's like he's just when these guys
that like feel like he had to have the
best house in the neighborhood and just
keeps adding lion statues and I think
you just build a moat got a hologram
mill man is like I remember my childhood
from being in a little town called
Caruthersville Missouri
so what like again a small city
southeast Missouri so it was that kind
of neighborhood where you know you
didn't you didn't do much wasn't game so
like to have fun you you know your
neighbors we would throw rocks at each
other as a game yeah
you're supposed to play dodgeball with
an actual like dodge Bobby yeah but no
rocks we know was there and but it was
great I mean because you know you go
outside you race everywhere you you know
right thanks everywhere and tag sounds
like hell now
oh yeah no way I would even my kids are
like you tagging like 9:37 girl most of
right here you play tag yeah where it
out I'm go seek would be like go you're
great so what's it like when you go back
home today are they like excited that
you're super famous do they not care my
family doesn't care no they care because
you know you can't usually gonna come
back in with some good gifts or
something that's the main thing but
after that part then you're back regular
but I think that's the big thing about
going home is that the expectation of
who you know and who you met man they
call me Tony
that's my at home name coin what did
they are like
wait have you know what is in there like
[Laughter]
you have your you have a thing called a
yard accused yeah what is that well this
is uh this was something we had to do
for television but basically we did a
barbecue in the front yard and actually
it's all about like getting people to
come and be a part of usually people
barbecue in their backyards and it's
only an invited guest but when you do it
yard akyuu you're doing it in the front
yard and it's more like a block party
it's more like welcome to come
do you ever have people though you're
like bye-bye sure wait you aren't
invited you don't get people that mix it
up for a yard sale they like using these
bro no it's some brisket on there right
now I totally grew up with garage shells
as well
well you I heard that you're now a
grandpa is that better of course I mean
you know it I wasn't really ready to be
a grand Paris you know most of us we see
ourselves as young and in grandfather's
like I don't know how to fix a washing
machine
you know she's a sweetheart
so she calls me pop see man you just
want to get my little grand cookie
that's what I call that's great but it's
like you say being the grandparent you
get to have the fun cute moments and
then you go okay they're so cute but
they could be so mean and I can't wait
like to be a grandpa because then you
load them up with sugar to me like yeah
yeah everything she can have it all and
then I'm like okay bye-bye
I'm like peace what is it like when you
go into a barber shop I'm just curious
Oh cuz I mean you know everybody want to
do the job
yeah what do you know I have and I like
barbershops I still love the energy
because of that that you know that kind
of country-club mentality you go in and
everybody just talking trash you don't
get to go as much but I still do that
like even on my show I had a room
designed like a barber shop so that
people just come there and hang out well
I'll get my hair cut guys they cool
great idea you're so inclusive yeah you
like it you don't like anybody around
with you I love people around that's my
problem
oh no my husband is like sometimes it's
fine to be alone because my husband is
surrounded by women oh yeah a lot of
sister wives some women or men would
love that but mine's not as excited as
oh yeah same here same here my wife's
sister a mother and my wife loves people
with so many people at our house I know
at times I'm just like hey nice to meet
you whoever you are welcome to my living
room I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this